Watson Data Platform is a integrated set
of tools and services that helps
companies accelerate their shift to
become data-driven organizations now
every member of your team can help solve
business problems by using data to ask
questions extract meaningful insights
and deploy them to your systems and apps
with Watson data platform you can
prepare store and analyze your data and
deploy smart applications that
differentiate your business say you want
to solve a business problem using data
first you'll need to make that data
usable Watson data platforms data
shaping tools make it easy to quickly
transform large amounts of raw data
including customer social weather and
IOT data into structured quality data
your team can consume no matter where
it's stored or what format it's in using
data catalog you can index classify and
govern your data with greater efficiency
ensuring you stay up to speed with
emerging regulations this governance
gives the right people on your team
access to data so they can create
visualizations and perform analytics in
a collaborative environment using
familiar open-source tools and services
your team can also build and deploy
advanced analytics apps in less time
using a combined Hadoop and spark
service that integrates with IBM's cloud
object storage Watson machine learning
combined with Watson services allows
your team to personalize your apps with
chat BOTS and recommendation engines
that deliver continuously engaging
customer experiences machine learning
models further enhance your app with
predictive capabilities that make
smarter decisions and solve problems no
matter what type of data you're working
with your team can realize the impact of
data and accelerate your shift to
becoming a data-driven business with
Watson data platform